what do you think the biggest moment in  the history of Bitcoin was the biggest  moment in Bitcoin is when Satoshi walked  away but we don't even know if that's a  real guy that's why I think it's  important it's like one of the most  selfless acts in the world you create  this digital decentralized peer-to-peer  software payment system and then you  have 800 000 Bitcoin and you walk away  and you never touch them oh so he just  still has them yeah they're sitting in a  wallet you can see them they never moved  800 000 Bitcoin I don't care if that  price is ten dollars or is 69 000 is a  lot of money it's a system where there  are rules but not rulers there's nobody  who's gonna change the code right  there's nobody who is the CEO like it is  a truly decentralized system and the  fact that we don't know who Satoshi is  means that you can't attack it